this video was sponsored by bespoke post
[Music]
there are only a few things in life that
a man truly desires
power money and sex nothing wrong with
that and in today's world there are many
routes you can take to get said power
money and sex
you could get a job is there anyone that
really wants to join the rat race and
slave away for the rest of their lives
to earn out most a meager level of power
money and sex
next well okay you could start a
business that's pretty cool
yeah but then you actually have to work
hard and suck up the customers and stuff
and we're not about that life
next you could become a famous celebrity
or athlete but if you're here wondering
what route to take in life you probably
weren't blessed with artistic or
athletic abilities
well it looks like we might just have to
be plus forever
darn it but before you give up hope
there's one more route you can take
a route where instead of putting
customers first customers want to give
you money tax-free money
instead of sucking up to your boss
you're the boss that people don't just
follow
but worship and when someone worships
you you could easily get them in bed
with you
enter cults cult leaders get so much
power money and sex that it would make
the kings and tyrants of the past very
jealous of you
like the moon is a korean couple that
became billionaires from their co-empire
you get to sit at the top of society but
not as a dictator or a politician
but as a god your disciples don't view
you as ruling over them
even though you are but as their
benevolent leaders showing them the
light to salvation
a leader that though figuratively and
literally followed to the ends of the
earth
now that is real power so obviously the
only logical route is to become a cult
leader
the only problem is unconventional
routes in life requires some rather
unconventional slightly manipulative
tactics
so let's learn the art of the cult
when you think of coats you typically
imagine some rather crazy people doing
weird rituals getting abused
polygamy drinking kool-aid laced with
cyanide voluntarily the occasional
murdering
so you might be wondering why would
someone want to join such a thing
see cults are like wars people always
say to themselves that what
war would never break out here that's
just something that happens over there
stop being paranoid the same goes for
cults
most people including myself think that
i would never join a coat a charismatic
leader could never
turn me don't be crazy but are you sure
about that
because the majority of cult members are
usually smart educated normal good
people that were just
lacking something in their lives that
the cult was able to fill
as a famous philosopher once said most
men lead lives of quiet desperation
and if you can feel that void of quiet
desperation that feeling of emptiness
well then you have the makings of a very
profitable coats
[Music]
as an aspiring cult leader the number
one thing you have to understand is that
at the end of the day
besides the more primal desires of power
money and sex
people just want to feel important that
their lives matter that people care
about them that they're contributing to
the world
that they'll be remembered when they're
gone the only difference between a ceo
of a fortune 500
company and a murderer is how they get
their feeling of importance
and let's face it most people don't feel
that important in their everyday lives
this is what you're selling to your
disciples we're not selling word rituals
or scripture to our clientele
those are just tools in the toolbox what
we're really selling
is importance this is what's empty in
their lives
if i gave you right now a place that
makes you feel good where you have a
purpose where you have friends that
understand you and genuinely love you
that provides you with things to do food
to eat books to read new ideas to
consider
and in return all you have to do is
reject the society that didn't make you
feel
important your friends family education
and future along with a fair bit of
money
you're telling me you wouldn't want to
stay or in other words if you make
people feel important
they'll be happy to pay you in blood
sweat submission and cold hard cash
and the more important you make them
feel the less likely they'll ever want
to go back to their normal
ordinary lives
[Music]
as the leader of a cult you need to play
the central role in your group's story
and religion
either as a messenger or whatever god
you choose a prophet or even god himself
the one or the mind that was in jesus
that mind is in me
you'll have to decide that for yourself
you need to make them feel as if you're
their only hope that you are the chosen
one that they can't find the answers
without to do this we're gonna need our
own scripture
the good news is that there's no need to
reinvent the wheel here most codes
simply take bits and pieces from
existing religions and put their own
spin on it
see all religions are basically just
stories and myths that have been passed
down from generation to generation
and each time is passed down it gets
more and more refined until you're left
with stories and lessons that are
universal to everyone
stories about courage bravery loyalty
honesty etc
everyone can understand them relate to
them learn from them and get their
feeling of importance from them
so time has already done all the heavy
lifting for you
all you have to do is offer something
new the
absolute worst thing you can do is frame
your coat as just an improved version of
christianity judaism or
islam marketers and successful cult
leaders of the past have already figured
this out
no one rushes to buy a training program
on a diet they've already failed at
but a revolutionary brand new diet to
get healthier
oh yeah the same reason no one's gonna
rush out to attend your bible study if
you just talk about the same boring
stuff that failed them before
you need to present to people a brand
new opportunity instead of just an
improvement offer
maybe it's christianity but you're
viewed as the true father and true
mother of your children
and you arrange your children to marry
each other in mass wedding ceremonies in
the case of the billionaire korean
couple's unification church
maybe it's christianity with a twist
where you promised to solve the racial
and social problems of the mid to late
1900s
that eventually led to the commune in
south america where everyone drinks
cyanide-laced kool-aid in the case of
jim jones and jonestown
jim joe's also mixed in a healthy amount
of socialism and communism into his cult
maybe you can start a doomsday code
where those who join will live and go to
heaven and those who don't join will
burn in hell after the apocalypse
planet earth about to be recycled
your only chance to survive
or evacuate is to leave
with us or maybe you can mix in today's
social problems and political unrest
into a new cult where you have all the
answers
basically just offer something new that
is still able to give them a higher
purpose making the world a better place
unifying races
whatever if you insist on creating a
completely brand new religion like
scientology with aliens or whatever
have at it just make sure you keep the
structure and lessons from existing
religions to make sure it has the same
effect on the human mind
now that you have your scripture it's
time to start recruiting some marks
view each person you recruit with a
price tag as you get more people in
you'll start to get a feel of how much
each person is worth to you
give whatever you can
these people are pathetic actually
recruiting them is a little bit tricky
just like how we pretend to ignore those
annoying salesmen at those island kiosks
at the mall
if people sense that you're trying to
sell them on something especially a
religion or church
it's gonna turn them off sorry man i'm
not really into that
so you gotta be more subtle about it the
best coats are the ones where the
members don't even realize they're in a
cult
open up to them for them to open up to
you emotionally relate to their deep
rooted pain points and then when the
time is right
subtly mention that you and some other
really loving people do this thing
together and you should come and hang
out
once you get more disciples in train
them to be over the top pump when
welcoming newcomers
this will make people feel as if their
current relationships are still in
comparison to this new wonderful family
they found
wow this is what true friends are like
screw my old life
as you get more disciples in they'll
become the company i mean movements best
salespeople who bring in their own
friends
and once you do get people in it's time
to put that scripture to work
within the code there are a few things
you want to accomplish number one you
want to provide a new way of life for
your subjects
a new life where they lose their
individuality their free will their
ability to think for themselves
and instead they follow your beck and
call
number two complete and utter separation
from the outside world
both physically separated like waco and
the cyanide kool-aid code that moved to
south america but also culturally and
philosophically separated from the rest
of the world
[Music]
you want to ignite those hardcore tribal
instincts within your followers
an extreme us vs love mentality where
we're the righteous ones chosen by god
of course
and the outsiders are the ones that are
gonna burn in hell and are somehow
always trying to destroy us
that we're the right ones and the rest
of the world is wrong you wouldn't want
to go back to a society that's wrong now
would you
really work that mob psychology which we
have a video on if you want to learn
more
number three you want to create a
culture of donating to the church
after all we gotta have money with our
sex and power right and of course you
want to create some very severe
punishments for leaving the cults
that if you're not totally on board then
you don't have enough faith you devil
these can be real punishments like
social shaming or maybe even violence or
worse
which i personally don't recommend more
on that later or it can be perceived
punishments like how you're gonna burn
in hell or how you won't get beamed up
to the ufo mothership
and to create this overall atmosphere
within the cult we have an entire
smorgasbord of different tactics we can
use a lot with the typical preaching and
sermons
let's get donations out of the way first
start out with making donations optional
feel the love of god by coming up here
and putting a dollar in the box
but eventually you want to make it a
requirement to prove your loyalty to the
cause
that thinking of your own money as your
own money is sinful and selfish so you
might as well give it to god
today is another day and that's another
dollar the lord needs from you
so come on up and give to the lord this
is where mixing in those very attractive
socialist and communist fights will come
in handy
take the cyanide kool-aid coat for
example members were required to donate
25
of their income all their property and
all their savings pretty good deal
faith healing is a very effective tactic
if done right
now you probably can't actually heal
people but not to worry because we have
some very clever tricks up our sleeves
yes praise the lord you can each drop on
your followers before congregations to
find out what their troubles are
and then miraculously point them out
during your sermon you can use fake
actors that look all feeble in a
wheelchair and then after some grand
gestures
boom they can all of a sudden walk you
can tell your followers how people are
trying to assassinate you because of
what you're preaching
after all if the establishment is afraid
of what you're saying you must be
preaching some pretty revolutionary
ideas
maybe you are the messiah so am i the
messiah
i don't know i could be i'm not ruling
it out for as long as there have been
books dictators know just how dangerous
books are to the populace
same goes for your cults so tell them
what books are allowed and what books
are forbidden
and the last tactic we're gonna cover is
making your disciples work
humans need work without it we're left
to ponder about life
right and wrong whether or not this guy
jake is really the son of god
blasphemous things like that make them
build stuff clean maintain your commune
so that they don't have any energy left
to question whether or not i'm a god
[Music]
[Applause]
but don't stop there there are many
other code tactics you can use
all it takes is a little bit of
creativity so now you understand the
psychology of codes why ordinary people
will want to join codes to feel
important how the scripture you're
offering needs to be a new opportunity
instead of just an improvement offer
how to recruit subjects the culture you
want to create and the tactics to get
there
so now it's finally time to start
getting that godly status that you
rightfully deserve
but fair warning as you become a better
co-leader as you start getting all those
primal desires we talked about it's
gonna be very tempting to get greedy to
take it to more and more extremes
but just remember the more crazy and
abusive and violent you get
the more attention you're gonna track
from authorities and the press the more
enemies you're gonna make that want to
take you down to claim the mantle that
they were responsible for liberating
your poor old cult members
just like the mafia ex-cult members who
turn on you are your biggest threat they
understand your system the dynamics of
your cult can spread stories to the
press and worst of all
testify against you one potential route
you can take is to have your disciples
sign ndas just like how some mega
churches do with their employees
just an idea but overall just keep your
greed in check and you'll be able to
live the life of pure
power and wealth that only a cult leader
can experience
if you're considering starting a cult
you're obviously a man of class a man of
good taste
and you're gonna need to constantly
remind your disciples of just how much
holier you are than them
just how much higher status you are than
them the problem is running a coat still
takes a lot of time
you don't have time to worry about
appearances even though they're so vital
this is where bespoke post comes in
bespoke poses a monthly membership club
delivering awesome boxes of top shelf
guilds from under the radar brands for
every part of your life
from home and bar to outdoor gear style
picks everyday carry and much more
it costs zero dollars to join with
equally zero commitments
here's how it works they find a bunch of
little known quality products and buy
them in bulk
you take a quiz and tell them what you
like and what you don't like and they'll
find your first box
then you preview your box keep it swap
it or skip it you are in complete
control
zero commitment what's great is that
every box has at least seventy dollars
in value but only costs forty five
dollars
at least a near thirty six percent
discount once you get your box they'll
introduce new boxes
to you monthly while improving
selections based on your feedback like
their gleam box i include the very under
the radar burst electric toothbrush with
charcoal bristles for built-in whitening
this is worth 77 dollars for just 45
dollars
an over 40 percent discount or their
explorer box which included a bunch of
stuff
i checked out all the individual
products on their company websites and
confirmed that this box sells for around
76
not including shipping if you bought
everything separately but with bespoke
it's only 45 another over forty percent
discount the majority of these products
are everyday things that you're probably
going to buy anyways
so instead of spending 45 dollars on 45
dollars worth of stuff that you're
already gonna get
why not get 70 worth of higher quality
stuff with the same 45 dollars
so you cult leaders stop what you're
doing join bespoke post for free right
now
no commitments and preview your first
curated box by going to bspk.meshjake
and support the brands that help make
this ridiculous channel possible
the link is on the screen and in the
video description below
gentle reminder that if you guys enjoyed
today's video be sure to donate to the
church of jake with the link below
i mean check out today's video sponsor
but seriously guys if you want more
videos like this on the most interesting
and provocative stuff in the world of
business
click that subscribe button and turn on
that notification bell too if you want
memes behind the scenes stuff
me complaining about stuff you can
follow me on instagram jaketrend.io
that's going to wrap it up for this
video you've been awesome i've been jake
stay dangerous and i'll see you guys in
the next one
[Music]
[Music]
you